hello everybody
thanks for uh coming up to the table
today it was really fun hearing
everybody's stories about what what it
was like playing my games sometimes with
the parents sometimes with the parents
not knowing
um
so uh so let me talk about the insoft
was early days I'm a co-founder of vid
software and I'm going to take you on a
journey back to the beginning of the
company's formation are you ready to be
entertained all right
uh I do realize uh there's a lot of
doves here I do realize that there's uh
that some of what I'm about to say may
sound insane but we were in our 20s when
we started in software and we didn't
know there were any limits
um so I grew up in a wonderful small
town in northern California it was named
Rockland and the population was 6 000
back then
in the 70s I was massively addicted to
spending loads of time in dark arcades
and playing all of the games there and
getting really good at them
in 1979 before anyone had a computer at
home really including me I went to local
College when I was 11 years old and I
started learning basic from the college
students I basically just walked up to
him and I asked him what the words on
their listings meant and I wrote them
all down and I experimented with them on
the HP 9000 Mainframe that they had
there at the college
and to keep me at home my parents got me
an Apple II plus I was done going
outside
uh
I spent all my time programming games on
that computer
so a few years and about 20 Apple 2
games later I finally learned 6502
Assembly Language the language that all
fast arcade games were written in
then I could really make 80s games like
these uh but not quite arcade games you
know but home computer games which were
on the Apple II and let's just say the
Apple II was my personal home arcade as
well as only one more million uh Apple
II users back then
so when I was a sophomore in high school
I did some programming for the air force
uh when I was 15 years old
we lived in England then and my
stepfather worked for the Air Force in
order to get into the high school coding
class I showed my teacher that I could
program in 602 Assembly Language and I
ended up at the aggressive Squadron the
next day
I was literally literally coding in a
vault because I was a kid they gave me
false data to use with my code I can't
tell you what I was programming that's
classified but a very odd but true story
um and then after high school I kept
making games and by 1987 I was working
at origin systems
and my first job was porting 2400 A.D
from the Apple II to the Commodore 64
computer
and by this time I had made 74 games and
three previous game startup companies
which were called Capital idea software
Inside Out software where I ported my
magic 2 to the Commodore 64. and ideas
from the deep and I was 21 years old
so I went to work at a company called
Soft disc at the start of 1989 I learned
how to program a Dos PC there and made
you know a small game or a utility every
single month for about a year
and then I created a product at that
company called Gamer's Edge and I had to
hire the team of game developers a very
small team
so I hired John Carmack and uh Adrian
Carmack who are not related into my
department for programming in art and
Tom Hall came in at night to help us out
since he was already as soft as across
the hall and he loved making games and
this was the first time that any of us
had actually worked with another person
on a game after making them alone for 10
years that's what it was like in the 80s
it was programming alone
but it was incredible when we got
together
so while creating our first game uh it
was called slordax John Carmack
discovered this smooth scrolling trick
on the PC so Tom Hall and John stayed up
just one random night stayed up until 5
a.m making this demo uh that they called
Dangerous Dave in copyright infringement
the the next day I saw this disc on my
desk and I ran the demo and I watched
the screen scroll smoothly pixel by
pixel and it was a massive Eureka moment
for me it was like a bolt of lightning
hit and I'll elaborate on why it was in
a moment but if sophomore was born that
instant on September 20th of 1990.
so one thing led to another and we spent
about a week putting together a demo of
Super Mario Brothers 3 for Nintendo on a
PC
which they liked we sent it to them they
liked it but they decided not to publish
it because they decided to only publish
their games on their own NES platform
which was a smart move
no problem we just use the technology
for a different game for the commander
Keen Trilogy the very first Commander
King Trilogy that we made
[Applause]
all right so you know why would a side
scroller be a huge hit on PCS in 1990
well it's because no games on the PC
could small could scroll smoothly
horizontally
per pixel at the time uh the PC had been
out since August of 1981 but in nine
years no one had ever figured out how to
make the screen scroll smoothly that way
until this dangerous Dave and copyright
infringement demo which then led to
Commander Keane
so the commander King Trilogy provided
the start of the company and we made
these three games in three months
from September 20th to December 14th
1990 when we released a commander King
so it was a massive hit for us and it
was so popular that people cosplayed as
Keen for years at events and they still
are
so this game pioneered the creation of
game engines
so we designed the game as an engine
that operated on different data for
different games it was the only way that
we could get this Trilogy done so
quickly in fact in 1991 when we were
working on Keen four we started
licensing the engine for the first time
and it was a beginning of this modern
engine licensing business which today is
dominated by unity and unreal
so development on our games went very
smoothly and quickly because we stuck to
some core principles that are important
even today so through this talk I'm
going to highlight some of our core
principles I'd also like to highlight
something else namely this photo has
anyone ever seen this photo before
yeah I didn't think so it's hidden on
the Internet it's a picture of us at our
lake house in Shreveport Louisiana where
we started in software so the funny
thing is that people ask me for years uh
you know game developers are asking like
what is in this picture like what are
all these things so I analyzed it
recently and and here's what you see
this is uh me and John in early
September of 1990 we're working on the
Super Mario 3 demo that we planned on
sending to Nintendo we both worked on
this huge Dungeons and Dragons table
that John had
um we used to play D D on the weekends
and those sessions led to ideas for
future games like doom and Quake
actually
so Tom Hall took this photo
um the computers there were brought home
from work on the weekends because we
didn't have PCS
so this photo was taken on a Saturday or
a Sunday
on top of the monitor is one of those
Intel reflective astronaut plushies it
was part of a marketing campaign back
then probably don't remember that and to
my left is a notepad which was like a
task list of bugs to fix and then this
is our high level task list which we had
to get done to finish the demo
uh and this is Tom Hall's area uh on the
right where he was doing all the
graphics for this demo he recorded
gameplay
um of Super Mario Brothers 3 on a VCR
and he played it back and he's pausing
the action so he could duplicate the
tiles exactly in Deluxe paint too
the TV set that he was playing it on had
a 13 Channel selector on it and was
connected by an RF modulator
very old school
so windsoftware was formally founded on
February 1st of 1991 and we made 13
games that year
uh Shadow nights dangerous Dave in the
Haunted Mansion we you know all these
games uh that you see here plus three
other ones I think there are a few
others that aren't not shown here for um
the Apple II
so we actually took two months for each
game but we made two games at the same
time at least two
um and this was due to us having 10
years of intense game development
experience prior but it was also due to
one of our first principles
which was no prototypes
just make the game polish as you go do
not depend on polish happening later
always maintain constantly shippable
code
this is basically how we make games so
quickly back then we knew what the game
was we had it in our minds and we just
needed to quantify what needed to be
done and we went about working on it
until the game was finished there were
no prototypes for our games we just made
them but remember you know this is a
small team of four people and we could
do this in large teams obviously require
planning and prototypes but that's what
we that's what we did back then uh time
for a quick story so one day it rained
really hard in Shreveport uh in the
Cross Lake which is where lake house was
it was flooding everywhere and I really
needed to get to work we were furiously
working away on our games and I just had
to get back to coding so I just got
ready for work and drove down the street
and this is what I saw the entire Road
was just flooded for I couldn't even see
the end of it well I waded through that
that flood and water snakes and
everything else that's coming out of
that there was crocodiles out there too
um all the way to the house and
basically took another shower and I got
back to work we were so excited to be
making our own games in our own company
24 7. and also note that during this
year of all these games we moved ID
software from Louisiana to Wisconsin
which does take a bit of time out of
game development so we couldn't afford
to have anything go wrong while we're
making our games so you know at this
crazy fast pace so we created another
principle that kept us developing
quickly
uh it's incredibly important that your
game can be run by your team all the
time bulletproof your engine by
providing defaults on load failure so if
you have a hundred people developing a
game and it won't run then you're paying
for 100 people to sit around and wait
for it to get fixed so we recognize the
importance of making sure the game will
always run and decided to just
bulletproof our engine by making all
input solid so game engines typically
fail because they can't load they're
loading bad corrupted or non-existent
data and so checking for this and
providing a default for failure will
keep the game always running you know
and also you got to make sure it's
showing you what's missing so if you
fail to load a Sprite basically show a
bagel if the theme song is not loading
play something really wrong and
obnoxious uh Missing sound effect same
thing
so after 1991 in software's first stage
of company development is complete and
another important principle was in
effect
keep your code absolutely simple
keep looking at your functions and
figure out how you can simplify further
we wrote all of our games all the way up
to quake in C not C plus plus
okay so stage two is about to begin in
August of 1991 we decided to move to
Madison Wisconsin Tom and I visited at
that time and we found it to be really
nice you know Tom used to live there
while he was in college he grew up in
Wisconsin so we moved all four of us up
there and we started working on our
games only four months later were found
dead in the snow victims of Wisconsin's
brutal Winters that we did not research
and Tom did not tell us
moral of the story do your research we
knew how to program an assembly language
but not how to ask Tom hey what are
winters like up here
so after six months of this garbage we
moved down to Texas
[Applause]
so yeah so we have a new principal
great tools help make great games
uh spend as much time on tools as
possible I wrote a tile editor back in
1991 named Ted title editor Ted was used
for 33 shipped retail games
several of which were actually 3D games
like hovertank catacomb 3D Wolfenstein
3D Spear of Destiny rise the Triad Court
Corridor seven and some others
so it was January it's 1992. we decided
to go all 3D based on catacomb 3D's
promise so it's a game that we made
um at the end of you know for October or
November of 1991. it looked really cool
it just didn't play really cool
um so Wolfenstein 3D was a game that we
made yeah
Wolfenstein took four months of
development
to make the shareware version uh we made
the shower version and then we launched
the game with one episode of levels and
it took us two more months to finish all
six episodes and the handbook that goes
with it
in the first month it sold 4 000 copies
all priced at 60 bucks each
yeah math
it's a spear of destiny took two months
we made that right after Wolfenstein uh
it's a prequel to Wolfenstein and it was
retail only
and soon after Tom Hall traveled to
Kentucky to work for a couple months on
Wolfenstein VR
yes this is 1992 VR
so back in the days of Commander Keane I
discovered a small three-person game
company called raven software in Madison
Wisconsin I called him up we went over
we introduced ourselves to him Flash
Forward seven months later and we did a
little bit of work with them by
modifying the Wolfenstein 3D engine and
licensed it to them for a game called
shadowcaster
so shadowcaster's Tech improvements were
sloping floors and lighting and fog and
this engine looked better you know
slightly better than Wolfenstein 3D but
it just wasn't good enough for our next
game
so John Carmack spent some months
thinking about
how more advanced this next engine
really should be for this game that we
decided to call Doom
and So based on the rapid development of
our previous games we came up with
another important principle
we are our own best testing team
and we should never allow anyone else to
experience bugs
or see the game Crash so don't waste
others time test thoroughly before
checking in your code no throwing it
over the fence for testers to find and
put in a bug database and fix it later
it's really a wasteful cycle we didn't
have QA back then we just did it
so after 1992 it's off for a second
stage of company development was
complete
along with another principle which is
core to programming
as soon as you see a bug you fix it
you don't keep working
if you don't fix your bugs your new coat
will be built on buggy code and ensure
an unstable foundation and if you check
in buggy coat someone else is going to
be writing code based on your bad code
and well you know you can imagine how
wasteful that's going to be
so the the ideas for Doom came from our
DND Campaign which was full of demons
and we also really love the movie's Evil
Dead and aliens
Doom's design was really a mashup of
ideas and at the beginning of Doom's
development
we created a new core principle
are you ready for all these uh so use a
development system that's Superior to
your target to develop your game it's
something that most and nobody did back
then
I mean before Doom we're making games
for dos while developing on dos
computers like of course why wouldn't
you we knew that we could do better
though if we use some powerful computers
and a more advanced operating system to
develop our games so we developed doom
on Next Step workstations they were far
superior to DOS
Next Step eventually turned into OS 10
OS X whatever you want to call it this
also meant that one of our core
principles was upheld great tools helped
make great games and we could make way
better tools on next step
so do med and Quake Ed were two of the
most important tools that we had
they both really helped us create levels
and test them very quickly
you might not have known this but we had
five people on our team creating Doom
so after Tom Hall left in the middle of
Doom we hired Sandy Peterson and Dave
Taylor which brought us up to six people
unbelievably while making Doom we had to
stop all production and we had to create
the Super Nintendo Port of Wolfenstein
3D as fast as possible
we had a contract with the Japanese
company we asked a contractor to do the
work they did nothing
and then it would became a panic
situation right in the middle of Doom so
we just had to stop and learn
the Super Nintendo
learn the hardware we never had
programmed a Super Nintendo before
and we had to convert the graphics to
its format the audio all that stuff so
we were at Peak in software uh
throughput at the time and it took us
three weeks
I mean we had to learn the hardware
so then we jumped into making doom again
so we uploaded the shareware version of
Doom to the University of Wisconsin
server on December 10th of 1993 and the
excitement for the game was
unprecedented people were creating files
in the upload directory to that were
sentences like when.will dot we see Doom
right we were getting phone calls on our
unlisted phone number asking when it was
going to be out I don't know how people
knew this
anyway time for another quick story uh
during the final day of Doom's creation
we worked 30 hours
we crammed as many hours as we could so
we had the game running on all the
computers in the office to ensure that
it was solid you don't just burn in burn
in that game however on a couple
computers the game just froze the menu
could pop up but the gameplay just
stopped moving so John Carmack thought
about what could possibly be happening
and he figured out the solution without
doing any debugging he just thought
about it and he was absolutely correct
in a solution and we finally uploaded
this five minute bug fix and then we
tested it again the bug had been in the
game since we started making the game on
day one
so the beginning of 1994 I started
working with Raven software and
developed heretic using the Doom engine
and I wanted to see how an inventory
system in a medieval version of Doom
would play and it turned out really
great does anyone here remember heretic
[Applause]
and we also made Doom 2 uh in 1994 yeah
took us eight months
it was released on October uh sorry
September 30th and we celebrated we had
a launch party on October 10th
so in addition to this we also did the
Jaguar Port of Doom ourselves you guys
remember the 64-bit Jaguar
but again you know we're multitasking
we're making multiple games two games in
1993 three games in 1994.
in 1995 we started working on quake
we had nine developers which is like
four designers two coders and two
artists and I'm I was going between
coding and Design
and I wrote Quake Ed and was
experimenting with level design in 3D
again we just started with a clean code
base no code from Doom was using Quake
which was another one of our principles
of development back then
write your code for this game only not
for some future game you're going to be
writing new code later anyway because
you're going to be smarter and you're
not tying yourself down to the
limitations of your passcode so and get
used to inventing new things all the
time
in fact back in the 80s everyone wrote
all the code for the games over and over
again if you've ever remember the Ultima
series every Ultima was brand new
um so Quake extension was being
developed at the time by John Carmack
and the rasterization was by Michael
abrash if anybody here knows who Mike
librush is
he's a god
all right John Cash worked on the
network code he went on to become the
lead programmer of World of Warcraft
yeah so time for another quick story so
this relates back to our belief that
developing in a superior operating
system can result in a better game and
while making Quake we made a deal with
cray supercomputers
to buy a craze 6400 super server for
half price
our plan was to have our development
team connected to it to bsp and light
our Maps as well as crunch any kinds of
new data that we would create with
whatever that next engine was going to
be
um in this computer room in quake's dm3
was going to be full of cray computers
as a reference to the new hardware that
we're going to be getting unfortunately
cray was bought by silicon Graphics just
before Quake was done and the whole deal
fell apart that just canceled all deals
that were ongoing so the computer room
and Quake is filled with the usual
rectangular mainframes instead of
c-shaped craze
so after publishing heretic I started
working with Raven on hexen I wanted to
see how an FPS would play with a hub
level system and character classes
um and uh hexa was launched on October
30th of 1995 during this Death Match 95
event that was happening at Microsoft in
Redmond
in a month later I got Raven started on
my next game design which is called
hecatone
so it was going to be the third series
uh third game in the series heretic
hexen and hecatome
hecatoma was never finished as you
probably were wondering
it was turned into actually hexen 2 but
it wasn't the same design that I made
and during this time we also noticed
this small game company that was making
some kind of cool games like Raptor call
with shadows if you remember that
and we brought them down from Illinois
to make a game that we would publish in
our office they call themselves Rogue
entertainment about 14 months later they
released Strife which uses the Doom
engine yes strife
it's an awesome RPG FPS
and it was really fun it's like one of
the first ones I've ever seen and uh it
really showed that combining genres
could actually make a really fun FPS and
kind of add to it and nowadays you know
we have Destiny Destiny 2 and then other
FPS RPGs but Strife was the very first
one
also during 1995 we made the ultimate
Doom which was a retail version of the
mail order only Doom that we had made
and we added an extra episode to it and
then we also made Master levels of Doom
uh so it software was still nine
developers in size and we released two
games in 1995 while we're making quake
and work continued on Quake uh in 14
months after uh starting we released
q-test on February 24th of 1996 for the
world to test our internet gameplay it
was a death match only demo
and during the next four months we
worked really hard to complete quake and
we also released a final Doom which was
created by team TNT and the casali
brothers
and death Kings of the dark Citadel
which is an additional set of levels for
hexan
so One important principle that really
helped us get Quake done faster was this
encapsulate functionality to ensure
design consistency we were using C not C
plus plus
examples of this in Quake would be like
the torches on the walls we could have
made level designers place a torch model
and then a fire model That animated and
then a torch sound entity all at the
same location but then if we needed to
move stuff around something could just
get left behind in the copy paste frenzy
and you know it was far easier for us to
just create a torch entity that would
just spawn all of that functionality of
the same location
also back you know water in the game
needed sound effects they needed sound
effect entities all over the place to
fully cover entire bodies of water so
you adhere to the water everywhere
but you know if the water got modified
in the level and moving all those
entities around and deleting would have
been just a mess
so it was easier just to make the
gameplay water sounds when water was
being rendered on the screen so it was a
renderer level feature and it was just
out of the designer's hands and it
ensured consistency and it saved memory
we didn't have to have all those
entities out there and we also did the
same thing for the sky audio and Quake
so I released quick shareware on June
22nd at 5 30 PM Central Standard Time on
the University of Wisconsin Madison site
time for another quick story
so while Michael abrash was programming
the renderer for Quake he was
interleaving CPU instructions with FPU
instructions to calculate prospective
correct texture mapping and sometimes
while he was playing the game for just
one frame let's go in 60 frames a second
for one frame the game would show a
completely different part of the map
and he isolated the only instruction
where that could happen and he
determined that it was impossible for it
to be an invalid value that would do
that
so he had a friend from Intel come over
to the office and go through his same
exact analysis and his friend absolutely
agreed with him and told him that it was
a known error with the floating Point
divide instruction on the Pentium
it was a hardware error there's nothing
that we could do about it so we just
left it alone
this bug is known as the Pentium F div
bug if you want to Wikipedia though
so Quake is a game that introduced the
world to Mouse look which is just using
your mouse to look around in full 3d
introduce the world to a high-speed true
3D World with prospective correct
texture mapping and also internet
multiplayer
so Clans sprung up immediately as did
Esports and tournaments everywhere and
then Quake World launched five months
later
and so making games was and still is our
life still making games even today and
we love it more than anything else as
you can tell by our release of 28 games
and five and a half years by less than
10 people
so many other games were released that
used our licensed technology over the
years
um and here's a couple more of these
core principles that we learned from all
this work
so try to code transparently tell your
lead and peers exactly how you're going
to solve your current task and get
feedback and advice do not treat
programming like each coder is a black
box
project can go off the rails and cause
delays
and programming is a creative art form
based in logic every program is
different we'll code differently don't
waste time focusing on a rigid coding
style it's really the output that
matters
thank you very much for listening to my
story
[Music]
all right so you might have some
questions so we can do some q a and pass
around a microphone
yeah we oh I know people always have
some questions after that
hello okay who's my go first
um
hello okay okay someone else so we'll
we'll just alternate between these two
okay
all right uh so how did you guys as
programmers collaborate back then like
I'm thinking uh I mean you didn't have
git right so what did you guys do
we had no Source control
all right we had floppies
uh and yeah we backups were whatever the
state of the game was on everyone else's
computer
uh working together was great because
we're all in the same room we could just
say hey uh I just changed the header
file for blah blah blah here let me you
know do you need it for the next five
minutes or whatever I'm about to change
it uh we just talked to each other in
the same room we weren't over an
internet we didn't even have an intranet
at the very beginning we just had
floppies
um but luckily at the end of our first
year uh in existence we did get a file
server and we got Novell you know 3.11
netware and we got ourselves connected
and then we could actually just copy to
uh to a file server so that was very
nice still no Source control no Source
control even from Quake like
didn't happen until like 2000 and then
Store Safe really
what was the bug that caused the game to
freeze that you fixed without debugging
I knew you're gonna ask that
it was bait I just felt that obliged
yeah it was a mystery wasn't it so what
happened was
when when you're making a game you need
to control the speed of the computer and
the speed of everything in your game at
a locked time uh Source right so on a PC
if you hook interrupt 8 that's your
timer that's your timer tip and you can
also speed up that timer tick and we
have to speed up the timer check so we
can dma audio from say a hard hard drive
to the sound card at the rate that
you're trying to play audio but you also
have logic happening in the game and you
also have a renderer so if we have a
render thread running at say 35 frames a
second we have game logic running at
another at another timer that's not 35
frames a second usually it's you know a
multiple sometimes multiple 70 usually
so sound could be 140. the refresh is at
70 because that's what VGA monitors were
at at the time they weren't 60 it was 70
because they're CRTs
um and 35 was the actual frame rate that
we were going for say with doom because
there was so much going on in the game
that we would have one one uh 35th uh
one you know half of a friend one frame
would be doing video and the other frame
would do logic in Ai and all that stuff
so what happened was
there's a timer tick that counts there's
a there's a variable that counts from
zero on up for all the frames of of uh
of game code that's happening it's using
the timer tick value coming from the
hardware
and that is a 16-bit value that goes up
from zero to ffff
Doom is a 32-bit program
so what happens is it gets up to the
very end of ffff and when we add one or
we add whatever number to it it's 32
bits so it's going to go above that the
hardware will never hit that the
hardware will wrap around back to zero
and then your logic will never hit that
high number and you'll freeze
so what we needed to do was just clear
the timer tick in the hardware so that
number was never going to get that high
and then we could also when we're
getting up near that at that limit fix
all of the values that we're waiting for
something that was too high so that's
how we that's what it was it was a timer
to non-clear of the bias value
um and when we cleared it then it fixed
everything because all the calculations
would always happen because they're
still in 16 bits
makes sense
I wanted to know
uh yeah I was wondering about that
Source control thing so glad you
answered that um but since you guys are
going so fast how did you resolve either
conflicts and architecture you know
opinions uh you know you're submitting
the code and the floppy and the guy's
like what's this you know how do you
resolve those things
it's my favorite picture
when we were coding stuff we actually
like owned part of the code part of the
game so we wouldn't actually stop over
each stomp over each other's files and
if we were going to we would talk to the
other person and say hey I need to
modify whatever the memory manager or
something like that and then they
wouldn't touch it and then I would give
them a copy of that after I modified it
so it was like clear communication we're
all in the same room it's really easy to
tell everybody what you're doing
um so we didn't ever merge like we never
needed to merge no one was ever working
on the same file at the same time so we
just gave updates to each other everyone
gets updated in the same same version of
the code and everything went fine and we
never had a problem with it we just made
sure that we were talking to each other
and that we didn't use the same files
uh hey John uh thank you for making a
game that can literally run on anything
that's really cool so thanks you're
welcome for the pregnancy test Doom
so uh I like I assume many of my
colleagues here uh have my own personal
games and projects that I work on but I
find working in Industry it can be hard
to balance my personal projects with uh
progress that I need to make in my
professional life so do you have any
tips for someone who's looking to make
meaningful progress on a personal
project a game or something like that
yeah this is something I have to I talk
to a lot of game devs that um they
either like they can't wait to like get
money somewhere like someone's gonna
give them money they've never made a
game before they think someone's gonna
give money I always tell them you need
to do this on your own time like there's
no way no one's gonna ever give you
money if you haven't proven that you can
actually do something so
um when you are interested in in doing
the doing some making a game or some
kind of personal project on the side you
know what's going to have to happen
after work what's going to happen on the
weekend but it's something that's gonna
definitely take extra time and as you
can see I don't know if I went into too
much detail uh during the talk but like
when we're making games
like our own games we had a day job as
well and we would get in at 10 in the
morning and at six o'clock we're done
working on the game for the company for
that we're working at and then we
switched directories and we start
working on our own game until two in the
morning and then we go home and we did
that every day until we got that game
done because then we could start a
company and it was just like okay we
only need to do this craziness for one
set of games or something that comes out
that can then make money that we can
then quit the job and go do that for
real so
um it's always going to be a sacrifice
of time you know it's always going to be
how much time do you want to sacrifice
and you just got to figure out even even
working for a little bit even an hour a
day is going to add up you know so even
if you can just do an hour before you go
to sleep or whatever
um to make those personal projects
happen you gotta sacrifice
thanks
so I noticed you and your team were
suspiciously happy and productive for a
very long period of time
[Applause]
[Laughter]
which makes me think at the very least
you didn't do anything with your like
business side practices that like made
you hate each other so I'm kind of
curious could you just comment on like a
little bit of how the business stuff was
wrong like did you all divide up the
revenue from every game or and would you
recommend that same practice to Indie
shop today
yeah so when we started the company
um we did not have even distribution of
our shares like we had four people in
the company and we did not have we had
like
um
age John and I had
me John and and Tom had 25 of the
company and Adrian had 15 and then Jay
who basically just came in and just like
balance the checkbook every once in a
while he got 10 percent
and it just didn't seem fair that like
Adrian is working all day with us
why is he he's an artist but like why
wouldn't he get the same percentage as
us
um even if we're doing the engine and
we're like doing all the cool code or
whatever it's like it just made sense
that we're putting in our time and our
best effort that we should all have
equal ownership of the company so I
argued with Carmack about this and he
did not want to to um to do that but I I
finally warmed down and we
we'll let j keep his 10 we all went to
22 and a half percent each so all four
of us had that and then when we moved
from uh Shreveport to Madison because
Jay wasn't going to go with us he lost
US 10 so then we all went to 25 so we
were we basically were only uneven for
maybe a month or two before I got us to
even parody and so we kept it you know
we kept everything as even as possible
because
we were spending all of our time
together and it would just not feel fair
to somebody that all this time is being
spent but someone's getting less
um
and when we're making money we would put
the money in the company so we left it
in the company's account we didn't like
split the money all the time so
um the first year by the end of 1991 the
company was making 50 000 a month off of
shareware games
which some people just couldn't believe
uh because it was you know shareware
but but we took the money we just kept
putting it in the bank account at the
very beginning when we almost had no
money we only took out the money that
each person needed so Tom Hall needed
more money than I did and more money
than CarMax so we just gave Tom Hall
more money and it didn't matter to us
that he needed more money as long as the
company had enough money to take care of
everybody that's all that mattered we
didn't need to get paid back later when
we got more money or anything it was all
about us being able to do what we were
doing and everybody
you know being happy with the situation
not worrying about financial stress and
eventually you know after a couple
months we could then buy all new PCS and
and uh and then a file system later on
and just all the money that we made we
just put it in the company so when we
originally started we were making 27 000
a year
each and then we um we went up to 45
000 when we were making wolf and like
Wolfenstein launched made a quarter
million its first month we're like hey
we could go up to 45k
[Laughter]
and then after the Summer where that was
like two you know that that much money
was was not that much compared to what
the game was making when it really
ramped up then we went up to 60k
uh so then we stayed at 60k each until
Doom launched which was Insanity at that
point and then we decided let's get up
to 100K each and then we decided that we
weren't going to go any higher than that
because then we we could have a just a
stable Financial prediction at that
point and anything above that we would
decide to split it every quarter we
would figure out how much money could we
split leave tons of money in the bank
like we would want a whole Year's worth
of money in the bank and then like split
what we could
um
evenly depending on how much ownership
because we started giving ownership away
in the company to some of the other
people that have been with us for a
while
um but we all we all did it as a group
and we kept as much money in the bank as
possible because if we need new
computers like hey let's buy
you know seven Next Step machines like
that wasn't a problem there were ten
thousand bucks each but we had all the
money in the bank so we just get them so
making stuff and not having a problem
making stuff was more important than us
having a bunch of money in our own
personal accounts
thank you and would you say that's how
you would tell shops to do it today also
uh yeah I mean if you run a company it's
really important that the company has
money to keep on running and it's not a
month to month you know you don't want
to be worrying every single month so you
want to just like Bank as much as you
possibly can so yeah we're we still run
things like that great thanks
sort of a follow-up question a small
high performing team
how did you decide when to hire somebody
and then how did you decide who to hire
well let's see um
we decided to hire
um Sandy and Dave
probably about three years after we
started making games together
so we hired some new people we actually
we hired Jay and Kevin in um in April of
1992 because we need a Biz guy
and we needed more work on Art because
Wolfenstein 3D was turning out to be a
lot of art for Adrian to do like if you
remember there were 13 games made in
1991 and we had one artist to do all the
art for those games he worked all the
time so he was like he was worked like a
borrowed mule basically so he was he was
him but he loved it you know he had a
lot of fun
um but we you know we just there was so
much more work with rotating you know
characters and animating that we had
never done in a previous game because
hey we're in 3D now
um
that we needed another artist and that's
why we hired Kevin he was already uh
he'd been a really great artist at soft
disc and he was a a manager that we were
you know communicating with on all the
games that we were doing for soft disc
at the time so we decided to hire him
and I hired Jay out of soft disc as well
but I'd known Jason's 86. we'd gone back
even before soft disc so we brought
those two on we already knew who those
people were they're really great and
they Kevin cloud is still within
software today after what 30 years he's
been there since 1992 he's still there
I email him often
thanks yeah
this uh demon-filled DND campaign that
helped Inspire Doom can you tell us a
little about it what was your character
in it so
it's funny because the campaign wasn't
full of demons until I made that happen
unfortunately
um we it's uh so
you know just from looking at the the
technology that we created that there's
a crazy genius behind the programming of
this technology is John Carmack right
um John also was so genius that he was
probably the best dungeon master I'd
ever played with and so John had created
this world that had hundreds of
characters in it that all had different
levels of power and different
interconnections different motives and
it was a really complex world it was not
like murder hoboing through the game all
the time you're you know you have to
think before you do something because
you might be affecting some other
political situation so it was a very
complex world that we were playing in
that John you know had been created in
plane for at least five years
so while we're in this world and we're
kind of like low level still you know
level five or level six when we get to a
point where
I have to hide out in a pocket Dimension
because there's some really bad
characters looking for us and the other
the other people had to hide out as well
I just luckily hit out in this like
Castle in a dimension that no one could
get to that this guy named vade owned
and so vade had uh this book called The
demonicron which could summon demons and
he could ask them questions and he could
possibly have them do things for him
because they were they they couldn't
escape the Pent the pentagram that he
had that that he summoned them in and uh
and I was because I was just like there
and I was starting to learn some basic
magic
um
on my own John actually let let people
learn like dual classing but also learn
spells that you just make up but you
have to prove that you're working at
them so I was making up a pretty cool
spell and while
um evade was summoning a demon this one
time the demon was talking to him but
telepathically telling me I can get
anything I want if I can just give him
that book
so I'm like
telepathically thinking back to him
um what what do you have you know and so
I'll I'll tell you later
the next time vade summons the demon
it tells me there's a plus five ancient
dicatana
and a ring of vampiric regeneration and
some other artifact I remember and I'm
like wow okay so I use the spell on vade
to incapacitate him and throw the book
because it would only stop him for a
couple seconds throw the book over and
the demon has this book and the demon
now can escape the pentagram and he's
just he goes to like 10 times the size
and it's like uh mistake
and and he basically he's just like
here's here's your stuff but it won't
matter anyway because you're all dead so
over the next two months of playing the
game every weekend the world is being
flooded with demons onto the prime
material plane and everyone in John's
world all the powerful characters
everybody is just going down slowly
every weekend until demons just own the
whole place and we were all dead
I was dying over and over again but my
little ring was regenerating me and I'm
getting shredded apart again it was kind
of like um you know Doctor Strange when
he's in front of
I can't remember the name damaro
tomorrow whatever and he's getting
destroyed over and over again that
happened but anyway
that was the story of how the world got
flooded with demons and then later on
we're like hey well actually so we
stopped playing D after that because the
world was gone
D for its software but it was the
beginning of Doom because hey what a
cool idea
so yeah so that's how Doom's a demon
flooded you know Phobos uh anomaly was
was created from that idea
thank you
yeah good question
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
by the way this photo up here this was
on the cover of a magazine back in 1994.
hahaha
we actually sell this poster on our site
so we've now seen Doom run on all kinds
of Technology what was the origin story
for does it run Doom
jeez
um
we release the source to Doom in 1997.
um and then people started putting it on
different things other than
different major operating systems like
Lennox like they started to make it run
on other things and uh and I think that
when it ran on an ATM I think that's
when people were like hey this is pretty
crazy and and then people decided to go
weirder you know like it's on a piano uh
the keys on the piano control front back
Left Right firing all this stuff so
someone's like making the worst song
ever while they're playing the game and
then it just kind of went from there and
because it's so portable and simple
um the the inner loop on Doom that
renders the screen which is we called it
a span blitter which is vertically
rendering Columns of of pixels so Doom
is not rendered horizontally like this
it's rendered vertically across the
screen and that inner core Loop is in C
so whatever the platform is you would
normally convert that into Assembly
Language for the chip that it's on to
make it go really fast but chips are so
fast that people just leave it in C now
um and that's why I can just easily run
on anything because no matter what
there's no assembly involved in any of
it if you don't want it to to be you
know to be there so yeah I think that
the ATM was the beginning of it and for
me the really impressive Doom versions
that I've seen are the ones that
actually run on vic-20 or really old
computers because that's actually hard
to do make it run on ships today like a
pregnancy test not really that big of a
deal because those chips are today's
chips like there's lots of memory and
everything but going back to pre you
know 10 years before Doom was made and
making it run on those computers was
really really hard
but yeah there's there's a I think it's
desert rundoom.com which has just the
list of everything
uh as you talk through those principles
they really were kind of like just a
snapshot in time of of you know some
insight that you had working as this
team very closely and I I find myself
wondering like did you ever find that
you needed to retire or amend a
principal or did you ever think you had
some insight that turned out to be just
a really bad idea that you had to kind
of you know let go of
um well like the Prototype one
the funny thing is that sometimes that
prototype one does work like if you
already have a really clear idea and you
have the experience that has you know
that goes behind the idea
then making that prototype really
doesn't need to happen if you already
can see the game and you already know
that you've done something kind of
similar but most of the time you're
always making prototypes like even in
modern game development today
um there's this uh it's almost like
prototype driven development for a game
today where you would create a white box
level that's called a gym gym and you
would make a gym for a facet of your
engine usually it's a feature so if you
were moving around and you have specific
ways of moving you would just make a
white box that has all kinds of
interesting art you know architecture
that you would be moving around in it's
called a movement gym and if you have a
system for magic or do you have a system
for something you would make a make a
gym just to Showcase that one thing
you'd set it up just to Showcase that
one feature and so you're basically
proving all of these little features out
in these gyms instead of hoping they all
work together of course the whole game
actually is making it all work together
but you can really spell you can really
get to the debug of a thing without all
the complexity of the entire game
running if you just use these gyms so
prototyping actually happens almost
through like the entire vertical slice
of a game nowadays where you're just
testing thing after thing you could end
up with like 30 40 gyms of prototypes so
it's the safest way to develop now back
then we weren't being safe we were just
making things so and we knew that we
could do it and we didn't have that much
time there was no time for prototypes
because we had to deliver something
every two months or one month or
whatever
um but but I guess you get good at
knowing what you can do scoping and all
that stuff when you do it over and over
and over and over again
thank you
so uh I noticed in the principles that
you described a number of them were
about
programming techniques or tools that
helped you and your dream team be
successful one of the things that I was
wondering was whether there were any
principles that you can think of that
apply to human cooperation and the way
that your teams were the the team that
you had were able to be as effective and
productive and creative as they were
well it helped
I helped back then that each person you
know we had a really small team and each
of each of us were in charge clearly in
charge of a certain thing
um Tom Hall was in charge of of he was
the creative director so like what
whatever game he wanted to make we were
gonna make it for us it was like we were
trying to fulfill a contract that went
on for a year at the very beginning of
hit software's first year so we weren't
really like invested in whatever the
game was at the very beginning because
it was written for someone else and we
were just there to get those things done
but we're also going to get really good
at making stuff so um Tom was just
coming up with game after game after
game he just came up with all the games
that year and we were just making them
and then when it came to we were out of
that contract and we could do our own
stuff then it was time for us to like
all of us agree on making whatever the
next thing is because this can be a time
investment and it's gonna be for our
company versus this thing that we're
trying to help another company with
because when we left softest we we just
took off and it's like oh you have a lot
of people that paid you for a whole
Year's worth of games and we just left
so let's not let's not get you guys in
trouble so we made games for them for a
year
um but when it came down to like okay
now we can make our own stuff and we can
take as much time which is Wolfenstein
what are we gonna make and uh and so
that's when we needed to kind of agree
together what we're going to do and when
I came up with the idea to make
Wolfenstein they all immediately agreed
to it because we all knew what we were
going to make like immediately could see
it we lived in Castle Wolfenstein from
the 1981 on up to that point it was an
incredible game and and so we could just
see it uh but but working together was
um everybody was super respectful of
each other there was no uh nobody ever
would yell at each other like that just
doesn't fly
um and everybody just respected each
other because each of us had so much
knowledge uh of game development for 10
years before that point that you know uh
like I wouldn't try and tell John
Carmack what to do with the engine like
it just wouldn't make sense unless he
couldn't do something I needed I would
just tell him well here's how I would do
it and if that worked with his code then
great and if it doesn't then we have to
forget doing it or try and find another
way of doing it but but it was always
everyone was super respectful of each
other there was no yelling it was just
being very professional which you
usually don't find in a really small
Indie group but uh but that's what we
were like so and we also like being with
each other we liked uh being friends
with each other our current company is
is basically the same way we have like
20 some people we all like hanging out
together
um and that just comes from each of us
you know everyone in the company is
hiring the next person together it's not
like some person hires someone randomly
and it's like who's this it's always
everybody is involved in hiring the next
person and the hiring process is like
probably the most important thing in our
company you know where we're going to
bring somebody else in so even when we
get to the point where we like the
person that we want to hire we go
through a process of okay now why do we
not want to hire this person what's
wrong with them and so we have to go
through social media we have to go
through background checks that they
didn't list because we know everybody
and you know basically just like what's
wrong with this person and if we can't
find anything wrong it's like this is
great all right you know let's let's
hire them
um and so they get through the gauntlet
and uh but it's but but it's you know
we're trying to find a personality match
and somebody that we would want to hang
out with and uh and that's like that's
that's kind of like we lucked out at the
very beginning within software we all
liked doing what we did and we had the
same passion level which is critically
important for a startup at the beginning
that everybody is is equally invested in
putting in all that time because as soon
as one person doesn't everyone else is
looking at them going like what
so
it's just uh get lucky I guess
[Music]
very much
so after you started licensing your
engines it resulted in some amazing and
absolutely ridiculous games do you have
any opinion on for example Super 3D
Noah's Ark
it's funny because that was such a just
like a copy of source code for us
um
in at that time we were not gonna like
well let's not license it to them like
we're all atheists and here's a company
wants to make a religious game I don't
care go ahead have fun you know it was I
don't remember how much it was it was
pretty cheap but um you know we would it
was just like all right we got another
license like that was actually more
important to us than like whatever the
game was that they were going to make
um that was I think a company called
Wisdom Tree that made that where you you
feed some sleep food to the animals that
are going to attack you and then you're
making everything sleep you're not
shooting
it was really dumb but
but you know it was is a fun game for
some people
figure yeah
um even in your presentation we saw a a
slow but steady increase in the
development time of games and and even
today we're seeing you know games take
five six years have 800 people working
on them um do you see there coming a
point where it kind of a reaches a
critical mass and there's there's a a
big problem there I mean these are even
built on pre-made engines and that sort
of thing and yet we seem to
have ever more increasing development
time and problems uh purchasing games
yeah the um
the games that are that big are they're
very calculated moves by big Publishers
to invest that much money
um games like Assassin's Creed which is
a massive franchise that has at least
1500 people making it across about 30 to
40 companies all working together it's
not just Ubisoft but like all of Ubisoft
satellite Studios uh Outsource companies
doing art and sometimes code cinematics
you name it
they know they're going to make that
money back and if you look at something
like say Call of Duty
when Call of Duty comes out you know
they usually spend two years on a Call
of Duty game that costs you know maybe
100 million bucks but they make a half a
billion the the week that it releases so
they know they're going to make that
money back so it's not like they have to
worry about that risk assessment on a
Call of Duty game
um a new IP is a risk you know a new
thing that is not part of a franchise is
the biggest risk and they always have to
go in and look at the mechanics of the
game and all parts of it to go
what do we think this is going to sell
like at the market it's going to hit
it's very complex because sometimes new
IP tries to get a new kind of Market or
new gameplay that you can't really
perfectly calculate because you're
having to like look at overlaps and
everything between markets so
um
games do get big but you know Minecraft
was made with one person and
revolutionized everything and that can
still happen today so
um you know a lot of times in like I
look at the Indie uh the the Indie scene
as all the really cool ideas are coming
from there and all the big franchises
are the safe bets but they're trying to
push in small ways that are on you know
their own game in some way like a new
feature might come out like the Battle
Royale frenzy that happened recently
with player underground now you know
player player known Battlegrounds and
then fortnite you know copying it
um and that just started a whole thing
there's a VR Gold Rush that's over now
um you know there's all kinds of stuff
that people get excited about now it's
metaverse you know so there's all kinds
of stuff people get excited about and
they always have to calculate what what
they could get from it and a lot of
times it's going to get nothing the
money is just going to be gone uh
sometimes just because
it's it's like making a movie you don't
know
um but you try and you try and predict
and calculate as much as possible in
these really big games usually when they
put that kind of money into a game it's
already known what they're gonna get
when it's when it comes out so like the
really big stuff that people spend all
that money on don't worry about those
games not making the money back because
they usually do it's the games that are
like in the 20 you know 10 to 30 million
dollar range that are the the ones that
may be more iffy thank you
thank you so much for your time and
thanks for being here uh what test
strategies did you have to make sure uh
on your code how did you make sure code
had been tested uh enough or that kind
of thing and also how did management
work or did you have any non-technical
managers
for for developers or that kind of thing
okay so
um testing strategies for games was was
a
like that's one of the most important
things that we could do on our games is
play the game and you know there's a lot
of times where developers are not
playing the games they're like they're
just working and coding and stuff and
you know the game has a lot of bugs
because they're not actually running the
thing that they're coding or they're
just running the thing and not trying to
hurt it because you coded it but like
you need to ruin your code and and so
like when we're when we were making our
stuff we were trying to break it at the
same time and we played our games over
and over again thousands of times we're
playing our game like Doom for a year I
don't know how many thousands of times I
ran the game and that's just like it's
it's it's playing it but also trying to
mess it up by doing things that you you
know hope that the engine might not have
covered and uh and so it's just like
willful destruction of your code
and if there's a QA team at least for
programmers especially like from back
then when they get to the assembly
language level it's almost like a pride
thing where no one should see anything
that is messed up that you wrote you
know because then it's just like you
look at somebody else's like well yeah
well if you were good you know but so we
would always it was like a challenge
like you should not have anything wrong
with your code and you don't want anyone
else because if somebody finds a bug
it's like oh God you know we used to
send like laughing dog you know gifs
into gifts whatever you want to say to
each other
um and uh and it's just like a
good-natured fun but like when we're
making those games we played them over
and over again and any bugs that are in
Doom are bugs that we did not find while
playing the game and they're really
esoteric things that are rare to to to
find and once they're found you can do
them over and over again but um they're
not things that would happen normally
when anyone's playing the game and they
they weren't fixed after we found them
they weren't fixed because people who
are really good we figured they should
use those tricks to to you know as a
thing that kind of helps them out just a
little bit because they weren't like
really big helpful things but it was so
rare to find anything
um and just because we ran our stuff
over and over again so it's really
critical to just run your own your own
project or whatever over and over and
try to put bad data in and just try and
ruin it we never did unit testing like
the unit testing didn't exist we had no
idea what that was
um you know back then we could actually
debug with Hardware breakpoints you know
if something was wrong variable was
getting trashed somewhere we could put a
hardware breakpoint on the memory
location of the variable and when
something happened Hardware debugger
pops up you know and we could see what
that instruction is accessing what is it
you know and so it was easy to find that
stuff now we use all the layers of
abstraction make it really hard to to
figure out that stuff and with
management there wasn't any management
so we didn't have a producer to keep
track of the project we didn't have any
managers at all to talk to people about
anything it was just
it was a hive mind situation where we
were all working together on the same
thing but it was such a small team that
we didn't really need to do you know
anything like that when we were making
Quake which at the time for me at the
company was the biggest I was in charge
of the design team and John was in
charge of the coding team which are
three other people on both both of our
sides like he's got three people to his
right I got three people to my left and
that was everybody and and the other
couple extra people were you know art
and stuff which they were owners of the
company they don't need somebody to tell
what to do so um
we just manage ourselves so we didn't
have to have any anyone else in there
very rare situation
uh so I just wanted to start by saying
thank you so much for giving me the
Escape that I desperately needed
throughout the 90s so that was amazing
you're welcome
um also sadly I finally just actually
paid for Quake so yeah
um the question I have is how much were
y'all paying attention to the demo scene
say that again the demo scene like uh I
don't know if you're paying attention to
that at all like what's going on in
Europe in the 90s yeah yeah so we we
were definitely aware of the 80s demo
scene because we've I mean I've worked
on multiple computers back then Commerce
64 is really where a lot of that started
with it and also the Atari 800.
um but we didn't like we knew
how the demos like we knew how that code
worked but it wouldn't help us in our
game because our game is not like these
really tight cycles of Assembly Language
doing mathematically interesting
calculations it's like we have to have
code that works on a lot of data and
none of it is tricks really it's like
demo scene stuff but we have kept track
of it for a really long time I mean
there's a lot of really cool demo scene
stuff still happening today
um and I still haven't been to assembly
yet which I think takes place in
Helsinki or something and it's like one
of the coolest shows ever but I Do
download those those 64k demos or even
some that were really big that do like
mind-blowing stuff but the demo scene
was always something that was really
interesting and I know some of the
people from the demo scene went on to
make Max Payne and some other uh really
cool games so yeah I mean really good
programmers are in the demo scene
awesome thank you
hi I was reminded of a phrase It's not a
bug it's a feature so I wanted to know
if you happen to have any favorite happy
accidents while you were developing
well see the um the bug that is now a
feature
in Doom like I had mentioned that there
were some things that we didn't test
that we left in the game one of them is
um when you when you as a the player got
one sound channel we didn't like if the
player if the player was going to press
the use button on a wall we didn't want
that to happen on a bunch of channels of
audio you know like 10 eat up 10 or even
like max out the amount of available
channels we want to just keep it on one
channel and just stop the current sound
playing and start the next one over just
stomping over itself because then it
didn't eat up all these channels which
could mess up the game and it would
sound really bad if you have all these
monsters moving around and you know all
this other stuff is happening and you
were just trashing it with using the
fire button or you know or the use
button on the wall so
because the player only had one channel
for their audio you could
you could uh when you fired a gun you
know the gun sound happens
um on the same channel that when you
press the use button happens so that
doesn't mean that doesn't matter really
except for when you talk about The BFG
because when you press the button to
launch The BFG it takes maybe a half to
a quarter second before you hear
something because it's a build up
and it's a really big you know weapon so
during that build up you can press
spacebar on a wall and kill the sound of
the BFG launching which in Death Match
is pretty great because nobody knows
it's coming
so it's called The Silent BFG trick
where
um somebody could be down a hall and
just you're you're like right next to
the hall so you press the BFG button and
immediately press the use button and
then you just walk out and it just
launches this silent big green ball down
the hallway and then if you want to to
be even worse if there's another place
where you can see run down that hallway
while the green ball is going this way
you run down the hallway to another
hallway and when the green ball hits the
wall over there you kill everybody in
front of you in this hallway because of
the way the BFG works it sends out a
bunch of damage Rays when it impacts the
wall from where you're at it sends out
damage raise so you can launch it over
over here run over here and then kill
everybody and they're like what just
happened
so like pros Doom Pros do that all the
time silent BFG and you can hear someone
doing a silent BFG so it's if you're
really good you'll know that they're
doing that you know so there's a lot of
psychology in really high level Doom
play and I actually still play Doom
Deathmatch at tournaments all over the
world still so there's all those stupid
tricks happening constantly
thank you all right
so you mentioned always starting fresh
for every game and not using any of the
old code but wouldn't you want to just
find yourself copying and pasting
certain things that you'd written or
would you always just truly write
everything fresh so uh we would keep
really foundational stuff that would be
dumb to rewrite file loading
you know like there's some things you
just don't need to rewrite unless
there's a new feature like hey we can do
asynchronous loading now or something
but typically those low level STL type
things we would just keep some of those
things because why would we waste our
time we would write the same code again
so of course we're just going to copy it
but when it came to any higher level
code there's always a new way of doing a
state machine or there's always a new
way of doing something so at some point
we're just like we're not going to use
the memory manager anymore like one of
the first pieces of code when we started
um when we started in software and we
started writing all of our own engine
stuff again the first thing we wrote was
a memory manager and the memory manager
would you know you would pass in the
address of the pointer that you were
going to to get memory from so it can
move that that pointer if that memory
around in memory and change the value
that the pointer was pointing at and
that actually worked out really really
well but at some point it was like let's
just use C malloc and stuff like
there's enough memory now that we could
get into 32 bits and it's like forget it
there's tons of memory we don't need to
like micromanage the blocks of memory in
the 640k space
um so we would do you know some of that
like as an example in the 80s
um in Ultima like Ultima was was written
from scratch every time except for that
tile draw routine which didn't need to
be Rewritten because there was no way
that the hardware was going to change
and there's no way to make that faster
like that was the fastest unroll tile
drawer draw code that existed you
wouldn't try and rewrite that because
it's already been analyzed by every
Assembly Language programmer to be
performant and not you can't even pull a
cycle an extra cycle out of it so some
things you would keep
and sometimes we actually did use some
of the same code like because of the
amount of time it took to make catacomb
3D which was only two months but you
know because like we we knew how John
knew how to do the you know to get a 3D
display up pretty quickly using
raycasting from hovertank which is the
very first one so we could use the ID of
hover tanks raycasting he didn't need to
he didn't need to come up with those
ideas anymore but he could he could
optimize the code for that the next time
he wrote it but then he had to write
like texture mapping code so some of it
was useful but most of it had to be
redone because the texture mapping then
when we go to Wolfenstein
um it's like why are we going to rewrite
all the rendering stuff
from catacomb again to Wolfenstein
there's no reason so let's take as much
as we can and keep keep it but we had to
modify it because now it's a VGA which
is a completely different renderer but
the idea of spam blitting these columns
is still there and we're still Ray
casting and it's just now we have to use
some tricky chain four mode VGA
rendering to make things go faster but
so we didn't it wasn't 100 it was
probably
you know we kept maybe 15 something like
that but most all of the rest of it had
to go
okay I think we're gonna stop here but
all right thank you so much John that
was excellent
thank you